this path began a long time ago a course  paved through human history that took us  across continents oceans and ultimately  to the stars for us this planet is home  it's protected us challenged us provided  us the foundation to become galactic  citizens but the time has come to  prepare ourselves for a future beyond  the Milky Way a future that begins 600  years from where we stand at a time  place among unknown stars and unseen  dangers and so you sure this call to the  brave the inquisitive to the  Trailblazers of the human race as an  invitation to stand on the shoulders of  those who came before and challenge  yourself to go further  begin your journey join the Andromeda  initiative today